there seems to have been a lot that's
going on in the last eight days mostly
centered around a quarterback in
wisconsin
but i'll tell you it has been
fascinating to me to watch this week
um everything that has been said about
rogers and all the different reports
there are
but i still think i i forget when you
wrote this it was quite a while ago
but you know aaron rodgers needs to come
out and say what he wants
and that hasn't changed
and
until that happens so much of this is
going to be speculation like mike
i have been told
stay away from the contract it's not a
part of this
of this dissatisfaction
you know don't worry about the contract
that's not it
and and so but you know i don't know
that
you know i i'd like to be able to hear
from the guy whose life is basically
being affected by all this what exactly
is going on so hopefully we'll hear that
soon but i'm not counting on it
peter i would say at a minimum the
contract is a symptom
of the deeper problem between rogers and
the green bay packers and to the extent
that i wrote that he needs to come out
and talk i would have mentioned your
point from a couple of weeks ago
that
we know that aaron rodgers wants to be
the permanent host of jeopardy
because he says so
and the
dichotomy between the candor
the bluntness
the honesty and transparency that we see
from him when it comes to
something that could be fairly regarded
as almost a pipe dream because i don't
think he's the favorite or even the
second favorite although the ratings did
very well when he was on the show but
that's something he's not afraid to come
out and tell us he wants
and to put that against this beautiful
mystery
and the ambiguities and the vague notion
he had a chance last saturday churchill
downs could have got on camera with mike
tarico and said i don't get this i don't
know what's going on here the contract
doesn't have anything to do with it
there are other issues but these aren't
unusual for a guy that's been with the
team for 16 years look what happened
with tom brady could have done all that
instead spoke to mike rico and tarico
said on the air there is a fissure there
is a chasm
between rogers
and the front office that's the record
that's the narrative and rogers has had
an opportunity to shout it down and he
hasn't
and after he spoke to toriko
and authorized tarico presumably to say
what he said
that's where we are that's what we've
heard directly the closest thing to what
we've directly heard from aaron rodgers
is what he said to torico and it seemed
to confirm
that there is a major situation
unfolding between player and team even
though we may not know all of the
specifics so until he speaks peter
that's the closest he's come to speaking
and that's done nothing to push back
against any of what we've been hearing
reporting on speculating on or otherwise
filling the void because he won't come
out and say what he wants what the
problem is
whether he's going to show up however
it's going to play out between him and
the packers
the one thing i i think
that we can fairly say
is there some commonalities between the
aaron rodgers story and the russell
wilson story
in that in the aaron rodgers story
basically
you know it isn't so much of what aaron
rodgers basically has said
it's what has leaked out around him now
russell wilson said some things to dan
patrick obviously
but i do think that a lot of this mic
is about when when russell wilson was
talking about how
hey listen i just want to be
i just want to be kept apprised i just
want to be part of
even the the the sort of the netherworld
decision making process i want to be
more involved in what we're calling in
the game i want you know that stuff i
don't want to tell john schneider who to
pick
but if we got a practice squad receiver
that has got to be elevated and we got
three practice squad receivers or two
i'd like to have a say in which one
because i can tell them which one i most
have chemistry with
i think a lot of that stuff is the same
with aaron rodgers i think
my sense is he just doesn't think they
value
his opinion in any way
and so that probably to me
is something that's going to have to get
fixed if he goes back
and and i don't think quite honestly
that that's that hard to get fixed
really i don't i mean
is there anything
that would be so difficult
about aaron rodgers having a
conversation
once a week or once every 10 days with
brian goodikunst about the roster about
the guys he likes or anything like that
in my opinion this is this is just what
i think we're in a different era
of sports mike and i can hear a lot of
people right now saying hey it's not his
job the packers are doing just fine
without him
i get it it's not his job but i'm going
to tell you one thing
that in 2018
sean payton allowed me into his saturday
night meeting with his quarterbacks
and his offensive staff and drew brees
sat there and told him what he wanted to
call
in the course of the game and i asked
peyton at the end of that meeting these
46 plays that brees likes how many do
you hope you you can call tomorrow he
goes i'm gonna try to call everyone
and so and i that isn't personnel
but that is the kind of inclusivity that
i think that aaron rodgers is looking
for
i got two points to make and the first
one is that there are similarities i
agree with you between aaron rodgers and
russell wilson there's one big
difference however the seahawks have not
drafted wilson's eventual replacement
and gotten to a point in wilson's
contract where they have year to year
flexibility that's the thing that rogers
has wanted to blow up and peter i heard
from that 48 hour period right after the
nfc championship when rogers first
introduced this concept that maybe my
future is in doubt before he cleaned it
up and he and he cleaned it up then
that's what makes the silence this time
around even more deafening
but
the idea that he wanted certainty he
didn't want to be a year-to-year
employee he didn't want to have this
specter of jordan love looming over him
this idea that they're using jordan love
to manipulate him to be pissed off just
enough to go out and have an mvp
performance and if he doesn't we're
going to go to jordan love and then
we're going to trade you that's the big
difference between wilson and rogers but
as to the point
that some of these old school krusty
football guys and you made the point in
football morning in america this week
that this goodikoon's mindset as it
relates to rogers dates back to ron
wolfe employees
are here management is here
players play coaches coach general
managers generally manage everybody has
their role
i'm a firm believer
that if a team expects the quarterback
to essentially be
the manager on the shop floor
expects the quarterback to set the
example by showing up earlier than
everyone else by staying later than
everyone else by holding his co-workers
accountable in a way that only a
co-worker can
you want the quarterback to do all these
things that make him a quasi-member of
management
and then when it's time to show up to
the manager's lounge
or the retreat or the meeting
they tell you nope sorry managers only
that that attitude doesn't reconcile
with everything they want quarterbacks
in today's game to do
i couldn't agree more and i i also think
that
you know
if your most important employee
who you're giving 15 to 18 of the salary
cap to every year if he's your most
important employee
don't you want to make absolutely sure
that that employee
is relaying positive messages throughout
the team that he leads
i mean
i can only imagine
you know the eye rolling that aaron
rodgers has done at times
in the last year or so or however long
it's been
you know over various things that happen
in this organization you don't want your
quarterback to be doing that it's like
i would bet drew brees is
quite honestly a great representative or
was a great representative for mickey
loomis and sean payton the gm and coach
in the new orleans locker room
and that's because he felt valued he
felt like he was involved
and and so i think the other
big part of this mic
is that
when aaron rodgers goes to work every
day he wants to feel in my opinion like
he is valued like
he he it's okay if he went up and he
told the boss his opinion about
something
and
i just think right now
he feels like
i am totally
not valued my opinion is not valued and
so i think that is where
that's bigger than the contract it's
bigger than everything right now and
that somehow someway has to get fixed
but like i would
i
i was gonna say before mike that that
mark murphy in my opinion can fix this
you know the president of the packers he
can fix this he can basically
mandate is too strong a word but he
could suggest i would not be surprised
at all
if in these
fly
these flights to the west coast have
resulted in them saying okay
here's what we will do in the future
whether that has happened or whether it
will happen mark murphy can definitely
make that happen
my best understanding peter is there
have been three such trips this
off-season in an effort to placate aaron
rodgers but
obviously
whatever has been said during those
meetings or otherwise
hasn't
worked which is one of the reasons why
we are where we are so are they at
impasse have they done everything they
can to try to find a middle ground and
they have just decided there is no
middle ground we have to do what we have
to do and that remains to be seen what
each side will do you mentioned the eye
rolling that aaron rodgers can do to
influence teammates we have reports this
week indicating he's doing more than
simply rolling his eyes the report from
bob mcginn of the athletic that in group
text messages
he refers derisively rogers does to
brian gouda kunst is jerry krause
although every gm in the nfl should love
to be jerry krause because he put
together a team that won six
championships but when you use jerry
krause in that context it's not
complimentary it's because he was the
reviled general manager who screwed up
the bulls and was responsible for the
last dance and tore it all down and
michael jordan hated him and that was
the context jerry krause used it and
then peter
the report from my girl follow of nfl
media that rogers was telling packers
players who were going to become free
agents i'm not going to be here next
year factor that into your
planning for your own football future
that's an example as is the group text
of tangible things a quarterback can do
to undermine
a teammate's faith in the organization
yeah and i think those things you're
you're absolutely right those things
look
i maybe he said that to corey linsley i
you know i don't know maybe the packers
uh you know just understood that
somebody was gonna blow corey linsley
out of the water with an offer which you
know he got a great deal in with the
chargers
but be that as it may
you know i definitely think the
uh the jerry kraus stuff that bob mcginn
wrote about that'd be really concerning
to me
um but
i also agree with you this
this stuff
i kind of think it's revision is history
and look i'm not a huge basketball guy
but the fact is jerry krause
you know i i i think he did not draft
michael jordan
but he basically constructed the team in
full after that
so uh
i understand that he is derisively
referred to
but
he also did a pretty good job in
building a championship team as well
they didn't necessarily give him that
credit in the last dance he came off as
the villain every good story needs a
villain he came off as the villain and i
think that's where the motivation to
call gouda kunst jerry krause came from
peter i have a theory
that in the absence of aaron rodgers
speaking directly he may be using some
surrogates to get his message out
whether it's john [ __ ] on cbs sports
radio earlier this week talking about
how the situation is fixable to james
jones close friend and former teammate
of aaron rodgers who was on nfl network
yesterday repeatedly saying that the
situation is fixable it's not about
getting the gm fired it's all about
making sure we have the key guys we need
to win championships i can't help but
wonder whether or not those individuals
are laying the foundation
for rogers
conceding recognizing that the packers
are dug in they're not going to trade
him their attitude is or maybe should be
pay us back 30 million dollars and
retire if you want we're not trading you
we don't want to find out the alternate
history of what happens when aaron
rodgers goes to the broncos and wins a
championship or two and then maybe after
three or four years the broncos decide
to let him go and he comes back to the
nfc north and plays for the vikings like
brett favre did we don't want to go
through that again we're content to take
back 30 million dollars and use that to
buy other players and move on with
jordan love if that's what you want to
do we're not giving in and if rogers
realizes that
he needs a way to save face he needs a
path back to the locker room and i can't
help but wonder whether or not guys like
kuhn and jones are paving that that path
for him to eventually show up and say
hey i'm here to play football i'm here
to win championships i'm here to
entertain the fans at lambeau field
let's get to work and not have
people
say what the hell is going on here i
feel like [ __ ]
and jones
have either directly or indirectly been
commissioned to lay the foundation for
that your thoughts on my cockeyed theory
i don't know i i'm i i don't have any
reason to think you're right or that
you're wrong i i don't
because i just don't know
my information last weekend was that
this was probably not fixable
and that aaron rodgers was not going to
play for the packers anymore
and so but but look and so look if if
you were to ask me
what's the percentage chance he's going
to play i'd say for the packers i'd say
it's less than 50 50 but
it's just it's it's may 7th
you know there's basically three months
to go before anything really matters
you know actually four months before
anything really matters
but the one other thing i would say mike
is that
when you think about all this
you also have to think about you know
what the two sides the message the two
sides want to get across
you know you saw brian goodkins talk to
me brian goodkins talked to albert breer
over the weekend
and he told us both
that he told albert we are not trading
aaron rodgers and he told me we are
resolute
you know we you know we're not trading
aaron rodgers basically and so that
that's the message that the packers are
getting across now
and aaron rodgers message
is that he doesn't want to play for the
team anymore now
what
is going to happen on you know august
7th let's say you know three months from
now
you know that's a long time and that's
why i think it's always wise
in cases like this you got to leave some
wiggle room because you can say whatever
you want at this time of year
but things change time has a way of
healing things
well and
who has the wiggle room the packers
haven't left much wiggle room for
themselves their attitude is we're not
trading him they could get an offer they
can't refuse they still could refuse it
the bengals may have gotten an offer
they can't refuse last year from the
dolphins so the dolphins could go get
joe burrow they refused it the packers
could say no this is it this is our
quarterback let me run another theory by
it because this is something sims and
i've been talking about this week the
dynamic in green bay where there isn't
one person who can make decisions with
zero accountability to anyone else
there's no owner and my
cockeyed theory
on mark murphy the ceo
is that
whatever move he makes here
there could be ramifications moving
forward and the one move that prevents
him from being proven wrong is saying
go ahead and retire pay us back 30
million we'll reinvest that money in
other players and we'll never know
what may have been if aaron rodgers
finished his career somewhere else i
won't be made to look foolish for
handing a championship or two to the
broncos i won't have to worry for the
next three or four years that the
dominoes fall in a way that leads aaron
rodgers back to the division you know
with brett favre they had no choice
brett favre showed up unexpectedly and
said deal with me and they said fine
we're going to trade you we're not going
to cut you we're not going to pay you 12
million to be aaron rodgers backup we've
moved on from you they had to do
something with brett favre because he
was retired and he came back if rogers
doesn't want to play for the packers
anymore
and the packers don't want him to play
for anyone else anymore i feel like
that's a better move for mark murphy
because you can't prove mark murphy
wrong if aaron rodgers never plays again
yeah
but i think murphy's
i think murphy's goal in this
honestly you know and i know mark murphy
pretty well
his goal in this is to find peace in our
time
it just is his goal is to make sure
that aaron rodgers comes back and when
he does come back
that they're one big happy family no
matter how really happy they are
so that's why i think you know before
mike you ask what is the next step
and i asked good consent the other day
and he said well you know he he wouldn't
say
it you know he they want to handle this
thing privately
but in my opinion the next step has to
be
some sort of olive branch extended by
murphy i think i think it'd be smart to
just let things cool off for two or
three weeks forget about the off-season
program you know let jordan love get all
the reps
you know he needs that anyway so just
let jordan love do everything in the
off-season program and if rogers is
going to skip the mandatory mini camp in
june and take the 95 000 in fines or
whatever it is
let jordan love handle everything as the
quarterback
you know and but what's most important
now i think the thing cools off and mark
murphy goes in with an olive branch
what it will be i don't know but that is
what i think is the most logical next
step
and there is an opportunity over the
next few weeks for something like that
to happen but the otas the on-field
practices that are the opportunity to
lay the foundation for what the team is
going to learn and implement in training
camp if he doesn't show up for that
that's an overt act that will create
headlines the mandatory mini camp not
showing up for that is the proverbial or
literal middle finger to the packers
that will be headlines and then to the
packers that shareholders meeting in
july every year before training camp
that could get interesting as well if
this hasn't been resolved by then but
there will be decision points there will
be action items as this continues to
unfold and you're right there there's an
opportunity now
and i think the packers are wishing and
hoping and praying that some other major
story will come along and knock aaron
rodgers off the top of the stack it
hasn't happened in eight days who knows
when it's going to happen but they're
waiting for that now along the way and
that's
um
here's here's uh thank you the onion um
at one point this week brett favre and
aaron rodgers texted and farve said to
rogers i have a feeling you're gonna be
playing for the saints this year and
rogers said that's not gonna happen and
i think we can confidently say that's
not going to happen even if rogers
doesn't play for the packers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports